skurlock has his laboratory here
but it's kang and his soldiers who run
this stronghold
they will not welcome you kindly just
tell me what they want with zahidi
nothing good you need to hurry before
it's too late
stop hey how you doing
i'd like to see dr zahidi please
this facility is off limits you will not
get a second warning
don't let them reach
so
oh
so
you must die so many can live how many
of our people will you kill to save your
one man
so
[Applause]
thiago where's skurlock's lab look for
the stairs up to skurlocks hut
she'll be holding your friend there
people
that's what they injected us with
he needed bone marrow for the antidote
to work
all those people who escaped the war
came here to die instead
and i was next you think that was easy
for me doctor
it's random it has to be
except for you save from your own
lottery i suppose
how convenient i create the antidote
i'll keep us alive
how many exactly have you sacrificed for
your little utopia
i am not a monster i carry
the burden a few must be sacrificed so
many can live
what are you going to choose who lives
and dies
i don't hide behind a basket of stones
when i kill a man
he knows it was me
take as much as you can carry you didn't
have to kill him
he was a man of science there's so few
of us left
he was a self-righteous murderer what
does that make me then
his antidote god help me we're still
gonna use it
you haven't yet seen anything
oh august
oh my god
is that a native of enoch i found august
out there lost and alone
tried to give shelter but scurlock only
saw a specimen to experiment on
this this changes everything
no more it can talk
august it's all right they're not like
the others they're friends
okay you're free now go
home
we've got
get dr zahidi back to my truck
your alien friend just disappeared
august does not disappear
so much as moving ways we cannot
perceive we need to get out of here
i know a back exit through the caves i
can lead us out to safety
get tahiti out safe i'm going back out
the front door to deal with kang's new
arrivals
yakub i got zahidi out he's on his way
to you
i should have left your companions to
rot in their vile
mr wanted them saved
i won't be making the same
i won't have to worry about chasing
after you
we got
outrider we made it out to the convoy
your new friend knows this area very
well
i think he can be trusted
we are ready to go or should we see if
anyone else out there wants to kidnap
tahiti first
funny i'm on my way
what the hell did you see in there huh a
real
we move out right away east there's a
ravine to the east you'll have to go
south around it
you know this forest i've gone further
than anyone else
i'm not a deserter i came into this
forest because i'm an explorer
a voyager like you outrider
we're heading beyond the anomaly don't
know if we'll be coming back but
we could use a guide
let's become a regular clown car
my god we'll have to report this to
gutman
can't believe we've been next to an
alien civilization all these years
in this case aren't we the aliens
these ruins are ancient if beings like
the ones we saw sent the signal
it wasn't from here are you sure we're
still heading in the right direction
honestly outright or i don't know but if
you can get a receiver above this tree
line we should be close enough to pick
up the trail again
i know of a structure give me a radio i
can guide you
no